I've had some kinky sick
I have tried drug I'm not changing the
way I dressed our feet don't work the
final episode of West world season 3 is
here which means only a billion more
years of waiting until next season yes
for those of you who don't know wes
world has been officially picked up for
season four but before we get to any of
that we have a jam-packed finale to get
to and you'll want to stick around
because we have some new updates found
on the Delos website and a mysterious
audio recording which I'll show to you
and need your help deciphering so let's
jump right in the episode begins with
Dolores in Westworld recounting the many
lives she's lived we get this shot of
her in the initial hosts testing phase
before Westworld was open and we also
catch a glimpse of Arnold the human
Bernard was based on putting her
together she talks about how this moment
led her quote to you a reference to the
talk show later have with me the
interesting thing here though is that
she brings up the ugliness of the world
setting us up to believe her intent is
to destroy humanity something would show
later contrast with the beauty of the
world in her final conversation with me
Sebastian one of Sir acts henchmen finds
that Dolores pearl has been removed
after the EMP blast last episode it's
currently with Caleb who is guided by
Dolores virtual assistant to an old
model of Dolores in season two Williams
said these models were expensive due to
their many parts and later in this
episode Dolores says the Raiders are
really doing their damnedest to make us
believe Dolores is still on track to
wipe out humanity meanwhile at the gas
station where we last left off with
Bernard Stubbs and William a shootout
occurs with Stubbs being severely
wounded and Bernard having to engage
rage mode something we saw in full
effect in episode 1 of the season
William gets away however when the
police arrive and hold Bernard up but
it's not just any police it's Dolores
5th copy in the host body of Lawrence we
last saw Lawrence in season 2 episode 7
when he was killed by a West world park
quality assurance team we don't know
much about this v Dolores copy other
than he was chilling in Berlin for most
of the season has amassed a bunch of
explosives which will later be used to
stir up trouble in the LA riots and he
was given Musashi's briefcase from last
episode the roboam circle here has gone
full haywire reporting multiple
divergences we catch up with Caleb at
one such divergence in Los Angeles where
he's led to a neat i Doan distillery the
same company where Maeve met Musashi
loris he inserts Dolores's pearl into
the new body and we learn a bit more
about Kalos past remember those
flashbacks were he killed terrorists in
some American town turns out that's
actually dello spark number five which
was contracted by the American military
to conduct training you can even check
it out on the Delos website which I'll
leave a link of in the description below
the writers here heavily imply that
caleb may have done what the other
soldiers wanted to do and take advantage
of the
spoils of war dolorous even says this
really weird line do you care if I
didn't have this vase
or this again but we know caleb ended up
doing the right thing and that's one of
the reasons dolores chose caleb she
knows from studying del OSes information
on him that he will do the right thing
exactly what I'll do because the people
who built a new study do two bonus
points if you caught Han REO as one of
the host hostages here as well as major
kradic playing one of the terrorists
William here has somehow acquired a
$20,000 bottle of whisky even though
this dude here tells him his assets are
still frozen in order to save the world
William will need a jet in a list of
dillos assets worldwide we'll see him
visit one of these Delos locations in
the post credit scene serac has brought
back me for the third time and Sebastian
shows him the security footage of Caleb
Rehoboam apparently never picked up this
outlier so he orders me to hunt him down
since he has Dolores as Pearl the
streets of Los Angeles are in full-blown
riot mode due in part to Dolores azure
castration of paid rioters through the
Rico app on their way to insite they're
attacked by Charlotte who apparently
only Dolores can see she is mega pissed
that Dolores set her up knowing full
well she wouldn't make it out of Delos
she's conveniently wearing all black
along her arms which will later find out
his covering part of her burns in the
post-credits scene we find out that
she's kept the burns there as a reminder
of what humanity has done to her I
wanted to remember who the people are
when me even Dolores later have their
fight and Dolores is shut down by
Charlotte it's not really explained how
she's able to do this but it's possible
since Dolores here is made from Delos
hardware and Charlotte is hiding out in
a Delos Lavin Dubai that she has access
to override commands Dolores is slowed
down by May while Caleb continues on his
journey to upload solomon's new strategy
into rehoboam with the help of Ashe and
giggles he's able to break through the
barricade and gain access to a
helicopter drone giggles however doesn't
make it also shadow to this guy who
apparently thought he was showing up to
a BDSM party instead of a raid
Bernard heads to the address given to
him by Lawrence to find out it's the
home of Arnold's ex-wife Lauren remember
that Bernard was based off Arnold
and implanted with memories of him so he
cares deeply about her and their
deceased son Charlie who died of cancer
Bernard has yet to get over this death
but his meeting with Lauren serves a
deep emotional purpose Lauren gives him
a speech about how not letting go keeps
the memory of those you love alive
essentially giving Bernard the freedom
to move on from the past the fact that
Dolores set this all up is some crazy
planning speaking of her she's hooked up
to Rehoboam and brought back online
Ciroc even offers to let her join the
others in the sublime if she hands over
the encryption key she refuses because
she doesn't have the key at all that we
find out belongs to bernard caleb has
gained access to this giant delos
interface which is conveniently unmanned
but is stopped by sebastian who he takes
out but that's short-lived when Maeve
arrives caleb is brought before serac
both men believe each other is the enemy
I'm not the enemy
you are so serac proves to Caleb that
Solomon's plan will destroy the world
showing him predictions of future mass
casualty events population collapse and
the eventual end of civilization we get
a quick little shot here of ash being
arrested which is the last we see of her
this season before another big reveal
that serac is controlled by Rehoboam he
has a chip in his ear which may picks up
on you're not a man regardless he still
is her only option to gain access to the
sublime and see her daughter Maeve
pleads to Delores to stop fighting and
learns that she doesn't have the
encryption key at all this infuriates
Iraq who orders Kayla be killed and
Dolores's memory wiped
at the same time Maeve is in Delores
mind Delores can finally tell Maeve the
truth that she doesn't want to destroy
humanity but get it back on track she's
chosen to see the beauty in humankind
[Music]
now Maeve must make a choice help Caleb
and kill serac or let's Iraq go but how
come Delores didn't tell Maeve this from
the start well it would mean her entire
plan would be in jeopardy she needed to
trick serac into hooking her up to
Rehoboam in order for her to pass off
its access to caleb someone she knew
would make right decisions in episode 7
right after Solomon is done uploading
the quote-unquote final strategy to the
USB Drive we get this really awkward
shot of Dolores unleash the darkness
inside him her eyes flicker and it
sounds like she's uploading something
and the next shot is her looking at
Solomon not to mention she's physically
touching the EMP system which is
connected to Solomon so it's likely Rojo
booms access info which Solomon would
have was uploaded to Dolores here
solomon's access was the last memory
before you wiped okay this is how she
was able to switch REO booms control
from serac to Caleb all she needed was
to be hooked up to it the USB was merely
a misdirection with the encryption key
now with Dolores and Dolores plans not
one of mass genocide of humanity may
makes the choice to save Caleb and stops
Iraq she tells Caleb that Dolores chose
him not for his capacity for violence
but for his capacity to choose between
good and bad now that he's in full
control of Rehoboam he must make the
ultimate choice so he decides to do the
right thing and tells Rehoboam to erase
himself she gave me a choice
I believe the rest of the world deserves
one too it's interesting to note that we
don't actually see Soraka die here it's
implied that he bleeds out but the
writers are likely keeping this option
open just in case but it seems like this
would be a fitting place for his
character to end Stubbs is put on ice in
a motel while Bernard figures out he
held the key to the sublime in his head
this whole time
Dolores wasn't trying to exterminate the
human race but to save it all serac was
doing was delaying the inevitable and
just like Westworld had to be destroyed
so the host could be free so too does
civilization before humanity can be our
world had to burn down before we could
be free Maeve and Caleb watch as the
city descends into chaos but at least in
this new world you have the choice to be
whoever you
she leaves telling Caleb that she'll see
her daughter one day just not today we
then have our two post-credit scenes the
first features William back again in all
black he's on his mission to save
humanity by destroying all the hosts so
he shoots his way into the Delos to buy
research labs where he finds Charlotte
even though this Charlotte started as a
copy of Dolores she has changed paths
this Dolores wants to destroy humanity
but William is like not so fast I'm here
to save humanity but Charlotte tells him
you are going to save the world for us
she's created a clone of William based
off his data from the della sparks the
data which encapsulate Sol his violence
brutality and savagery the real William
is killed and it's revealed this
facility is making hundreds of hosts
with the implication that Charlotte is
building an army to take over humanity
but in the final scene we see Bernard
right where we left him but now he's
completely covered in dust
the producers have confirmed this takes
place far in the future so who knows if
Stubbs ever made it out of that bathroom
Bernard went into the sublime to look
for answers and he was gone for what
presumably is years we don't know what
he saw learned or if in his mind
time passed at the same rate as the
outside world this leads us with tons of
possibilities for what next season could
hold including multiple timelines which
could take place across digital and real
worlds I also want to take a moment and
talk about this mysterious audio found
on the insight website I'll leave a link
in the description below here's what it
sounds like unaltered
and here's what user Gustavo Lazzari of
Reddit was able to clean up it's almost
incoherent but it does sound like it's
Dolores and the last line sounds like
she's saying but you could read it if
you want to now I know there's got to be
some good sound engineers that can clean
this up so if you're able to figure it
out I am super curious what the rest
says feel free to DM me on twitter @
think story YT so I can share it with
you all in future videos before I end I
just want to take a minute and thank all
of you who stuck with me and watch these
videos if I have time I'm hoping to come
up with a season 4 Theory video and some
other surprises so make sure to hit that
subscribe button give this video a like
and hopefully humanity will still be
around by the time next season comes
thanks for watching give me a follow on
Twitter at pink story YT and until next
time remember daddy loves you very much